sept minutes pour séduire pas une de
plus le concept nous vient des états
unis et il commence à bien marcher en
france
des soirées très spéciales pour les
célibataires objectif rencontrer le
maximum de monde en un minimum de temps
et se revoir si affinités on appelle
cela le speed dating lors de la lex et
stéphane taponier enfin jeunes souvent
cadrer dynamique et tous célibataires
c'est pour cela qu'ils sont là ce soir
pour rencontrer l'âme soeur avait
forcément un peu d'appréhension
gc
sortez princesse partir d'eau
c'est vrai qu'à partir d'un certain âge
on est dans la vie active et ses plans
plan d'eau
hommage c'est vrai qu'on raconte pas
c'est très difficile de faire des
rencontres
lors de ces soirées de speed dating en
français rendez vous rapide les règles
du jeu sont simples
chaque participant va rencontrer en
tête-à-tête fait autres personnes du
sexe opposé
chacune pendant sept minutes le tout au
rythme du bonheur une seconde à perdre
mais tout à fait de savoir si on a une
affinité avec les gens on sait pas si
c'est la personne avec qui on va passer
le reste de sa vie ce serait vous mentir
que de vous doit sa le par contre ça
permet clairement de savoir si c'est une
personne qu'on peut avoir envie de
regarder aventureuse d'un port pour 2020
et batipart à new york
originaire des états unis ce concept de
rendez vous est arrivé au printemps en
france avec un prix d'entrée à 40 euros
environ
ses soieries font un véritable carton
elles ont permis de dédramatiser la
rencontre en disant parachute repas de
fatigue et on a absolument pas de
construire une vie de compteur après
chaque entretien le couperet tombe sur
leur journal de bord les participants
inscrivent s'ils désirent ou nous revoir
leur nouvelle rencontre au journaliste
très mignonne et le des mois 0,6 vers de
noter dans l'éducation je marchais un
ange passe
un enjeu qui pour l'instant est
uniquement parisien mais dès septembre
prochain le plus grandes villes de
province accueilleront à leur tour ces
jeux de l'amour et du hasard